you
[Music]
good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday and even though there's
like 7500 people watching me talking to
my video camera I am still going to
answer as many of your questions as I
can within four minutes
the first question arguably the most
important is this I signed up for the
mailing list but I can't seem to get
your emails why is that it's either
because our emails are going to your
spam folder in which case you need to
unblock nerd BOTS at brotherhood' to
comm and Hank at Brotherhood to comm and
also look in your spam for the emails or
else it's because you have hotmail and
for some reason the emails aren't
getting to you at all we're working on
that
anyway sign up for the mailing list it's
going to be the best mailing list ever
next question how much wood could a
woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could
chuck wood it is indeed true that
woodchucks cannot chuck wood but one
wildlife biologist calculated that if
they could chuck wood they could chuck
about 700 pounds per day will you marry
me that would make me a felon and I
don't want to go to prison nerdfighters
don't win in prison why is the name of
your website sparks fly up it's taken
from a line in the book of Job from the
Bible man is born to trouble like the
sparks fly upwards what's your stance on
gay marriage I'm for it how many books
do you own around 1,300 would you ever
clone yourself yeah I know how low works
out because I've watched Star Wars who's
Hank Hank is a mass of incandescent gas
located about 26,000 light-years from
the center of the Milky Way hank is
responsible for ninety nine point eight
percent of the solar system's mass if
you stare at hank for too long you will
go blind are you dreading the end of the
year or are you looking forward to it
there's a great writer named Amy Krauss
Rosenthal who taught me a word wabi-sabi
I feel very Wong he saw me about all of
it if you could live off one kind of
poison what would it be
that's one of those massively
hypothetical questions like would you
rather live in a house made out of human
bones or would you rather have to snort
all of your nutrition through your nose
every morning which is because it's
massively hypothetical doesn't mean I
don't have an answer House of human
bones and definitely cyanide because it
tastes like bitter almonds and they're
delicious what's the best video game
you've ever played Wii tennis 2399 skill
level for the win can an SUV owner be a
nerdfighter clearly yes Hank check that
out Hank up switched airports but I'm
still answering questions have you guys
ever noticed that Hank looks kind of
like Ryan Phillip a and John looks kind
of like Tim Robbins no I didn't know
that but thanks that doesn't hurt my
feelings at all Tim Robbins is 49 years
old what do you find so appealing about
Walt Whitman song of myself' you'll find
out when Paper Towns comes out when does
Paper Towns come out
September heat vision or power to fly
definitely power to fly our Kelly and I
have exactly one thing in common we
believe we can fly how long have you
been playing video games since Christmas
Day 1984 favorite Beatle John favorite
color green oh my gosh Hank if you
combine my answers to the last two
questions you get like me I think I'm
slowly undergoing a change from
nerdfighter and training to full-fledged
nerdfighter how will I know when that
has occurred you will wake up one
morning and notice that instead of the
blood that has always been coursing
through your veins your heart will be
pumping only awesome are you Mary Tyler
Moore I don't think so but then again
Mary Tyler Moore and I have never been
seen in the same place at the same time
so I suppose it is possible a man walks
upstairs turns off the light and goes to
bed the next morning he walks downstairs
reads the paper and promptly commits
suicide why the man was a guard at a
light house as a result of him turning
off the light a ship wrecked he read
about it the next morning and as a
result he was so despondent that he
committed suicide riddle pwned what is
your opinion of the 1969 concert
Woodstock I'm sure it was an excellent
concert but there's no way there were
enough public toilets and I have a
strict policy against attending under
toileted events if you had a monkey what
would you call it bubbles the
nerdfighting monkey what does the Yeti
look like she looks kind of like a
kitten wrestling a rainbow what did you
do before Looking for Alaska was
published I was the star of a television
show called The Mary Tyler Moore Show do
you think it's inevitable that humans
will one day be controlled by robots
unfortunately I actually think that
people will go extinct before robots can
take us over how many questions do you
think you can answer in four minutes I
don't know but I know this I can only
answer two more what's our scavenger
hunt clue in New York City there is a
baby penguin that baby penguin is
flanked by two baby Washington monuments
if you open the door to one of those
Washington monuments you will find a
prize when will you see Hank tomorrow